one of the things that I really commend
you on on both films is having a great
villain both times I feel like I
understand their motivation and I
believe in what they're saying for you
what's the secret in creating a great
villain wow
um
actually for me I don't see them as
villains like I've seen like like I
think antagonist is probably yeah no no
totally totally no no but I think that
word is fine like
I I don't I don't try to govern people's
words you know I should have said
antagonists
but that but that's kind of like how I
think Obama I think Obama Mash you know
this is a character that's going to come
in conflict with my protagonist you know
and and and it'd be interesting if they
want the same things you know you know
what I mean but but um but but because
of who they are and what shaped them
um they wanna they wanna they wanna they
wanna get those things in different ways
and their means you know uh their means
come in conflict with each other you
know and and it comes to a head you know
that's kind of like uh
um
how
movies are like or structured you know
um
uh
um
and and and I think like
you know Terminator 2 is a big
inspiration for this movie you know um
uh big time and and you think about what
what you know
um T1000 once and with Arnold
Schwarzenegger's robot once they both
won John Connor you know what I'm saying
like like but 21 000 wants to kill him
Arnold Schwarzenegger's character wants
to protect him you know you know that
but but that that's that's
you know that's the movie you know what
I'm you know what I'm saying and
um I I I look at it like like like like
that and
um
and also
um
trying to spend time with them not too
much you know what I'm saying but but
enough
that that you that you understand where
they're coming from and um
and and that you believe you know like
like when I when I
um when I make threats you know yeah
like like um you know that's what makes
net worth I think so cool in the books
like he's in in most run most publishing
runs in him he's very arrogant you know
um but but you also know he has the
capability to do what he's saying he's
gonna do you know like um he walks in
with his in his underwear and says hey
I'm gonna kill everybody you know but
you believe it you know because you know
he's capable of it you know um uh so so
we wanted to kind of bring that same
kind of that kind of the same kind of um
that same kind of swagger to the
Cinematic version of him you know but
also uh give it to give it the the
detail that you that you were recognize
in a Black Panther movie